[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar today we're going to be looking
at one of the most mysterious and
possibly misunderstood characters in
attack on Titan any led heart we are
going to go through everything you need
to know about everyone's favorite lone
wolf
no now you holo we will also look at the
female Titans unique abilities and what
sets her apart from the other Titan
powers before we start I want to thank
you guys we've actually doubled our
number of subscribers in a single month
and it's all thanks to you guys you're
unbelievable support keeps us going and
makes these videos possible this video
in particular was insanely requested by
you guys I can't even count how many
times so this one goes out to all of you
to all of our subscribers old and new
who helped us get this far we could not
have done it without you if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe
because there are many attack on Titan
videos on this channel already and many
more on the way quick warning there will
be manga spoilers so proceed with
extreme caution because we will be going
beyond the walls and through the matrix
now if you're psyched and ready to go
smash that like button and let's do this
let's start with some basic information
before we get into any secret paths she
is 16 years old in the year 850 and it's
technically 20 years old after the
time-skip even though I doubt that her
body's aged inside that indestructible
crystal she is 5 feet tall and weighs
119 pounds but don't let that fool you
she's amazing fighter her dad taught her
a fighting style that resembles muy Thai
and in combat according to the official
attack on Titan handbook she is ranked
and out of 10 just like Mikasa she has
absolutely no problem knocking riders to
the ground at a fight even though he
weighs about 210 pounds she also scored
a 10 out of 10 for secrets so we should
be on the lookout for some big reveals
in the future her Titan form is 14
meters tall a meter shorter than Aaron's
attack Titan and riders armored Titan
her Titan form scored an insane 11 out
of 10 in combat
meaning it's off the charts and a 10 out
of 10 in sexiness and judging from most
of your comments I
think you guys would agree her birthday
is March 22nd and here are some bonus
facts she came in number six in an
attack on Titan character popularity
poll and ISA AMA has revealed that Annie
has the habit of sleep talking
sometimes she murmurs whoosh when she
dreams of practicing her kicks on trees
so cute and yet so deadly
lastly Annie usually wears hoodies so
she can cover her head when she wants to
feel alone in public now that we know
some basic facts about Annie let's go
back to the beginning
Annie along with Reiner and better souls
are from Marlay which is an area beyond
the walls if you want to know more about
it check out my Amir explained video
where I go into the history in more
detail the main idea is that our main
story takes place on the island of
parodies where three walls are located
the LD ends were a race of people who
had the potential to turn into Titans
and use that power to create and rule
over the LDN Empire within which Marlins
lived eventually the 145th king was sick
of fighting and moved the capital of the
Empire to the island of parodies he also
took the power of the founding type in
coordinate with him if you want to know
more check out my coordinate explained
video long story short this power
allowed him to control Titans and erase
and rewrite the memories of other LD ins
he used these powers to build the walls
and make the people on the island think
they were the last remnants of humanity
however some LD ins remain on the
continent and without the power of the
coordinate the Marlin nation took over
they discriminated against the LD ins
who they viewed as monsters but they
also needed LD ins to use the seven
Titan powers that they had in their
possession because Marlins could not
become Titans thus the Marlin
government's warrior program was born
and here we will find a young Annie
along with a young Reiner best old Zeke
peak Galliard and Marcel in the 94th
chapter of the manga it is revealed that
Annie was much stronger than Reiner she
was chosen to be a warrior candidate
because of her amazing combat skills she
was the best in hand-to-hand combat
among all of the recruits
before even entering into the program
and his father had trained her to fight
they would practice for many hours every
day despite the fact that she was a
child and even though Annie claims that
her hand-to-hand combat skills are
pointless crap that her father daughter
Erin during their final fight realizes
that she's lying she comes alive when
she gets to show off her combat skills
and that's probably because of how much
she cares about her father it reminds
her of him and the time they spent
together when she was little she
eventually inherits the female Titan
power from the Malayan government and
sometime before she is supposed to leave
for Marlay in order to infiltrate the
walls and acquire the coordinate power
that's an errand she has a talk with her
dad he says that what he did was wrong
he doesn't expect her to forgive him but
he promises to always be by her side and
he wants her to come back to him no
matter what even if she makes the entire
world her enemy and every other creature
alive comes to hate her of course the
question here is what did he do that was
wrong Annie later says after sparring
with Aaron during training that her
father was like Eren carried away by
ideals I had nothing to do with reality
even as a kid she knew it was crap but
her dad made her learn those pointless
moves and she was too young to defy him
so what kind of ideals was her father
driven by was losing Annie his
punishment for challenging to Marlon
government or was he brainwashed like
Reiner into thinking that every good LDN
must do their part to kill the evil
Island dwelling Devils for the time
being I personally like to think that he
liked Grisha and Deena was an LVN
restorationist and wanted Annie to
become an LDN spy within the merlion
government but he liked Grisha comes to
realize that it was wrong to force such
a heavy burden upon his own child I am
sure we will find out more about Annie's
father and exactly what he meant but let
me know what you think about her father
we never get a clear look at his face in
the manga either which also must have
been done intentionally who could he be
and what will his role be moving forward
I can't wait to find out but whatever
happens it does seem like Indiana he
chooses to value his daughter above all
else and prioritizes her safe return
over everything else in 845 the Colossus
Titan and the armored Titan show up and
break through the gates
Herman has speculated that Annie as the
female Titan was the one who led all of
the Titans into the walls because we
know she can use her scream to make them
follow her however this has not been
verified
Annie then passes herself off as a
refugee with Ryder and best hold and
lives in our refugee camp until they're
all old enough to enroll into training
Corps and he usually walks around with
an expressionless look on her face and
does not try to make friends in the
training Corps she has clearly
standoffish with most people most of the
time including with her fellow male and
warriors Ryder and vessels she goes on
to give Erin private lessons in
hand-to-hand combat to the irritation of
Mikasa who's like stay away from my
boyfriend I mean brother baka Eren later
uses what he learns from Annie to defeat
Ryder which really makes us question
where Annie's loyalty lies in fact
during the Battle of trois District
Ryder makes any indirectly kill Marco by
taking off his vertical maneuvering gear
so that he cannot escape being eaten by
a Titan Annie seems to be the only one
against it she is crying and clearly
troubled and insults Ryder for
suggesting that they should kill Marco
Reiner says that she still has not given
them a reason probably meaning that she
has never done anything that proves
she's on the Malayan side he points out
how she just risked her life to save
Connie and accuses her of starting to
feel compassion for the evil Island
Wohlers it is only after Reiner mentions
her father waiting for her return that
she does it but afterwards she keeps
crying and saying sorry to Marco even
though she acts like she doesn't care it
seems that she does care more about the
safety of her Island dwelling comrades
then Reiner and vessel this is also why
she doesn't kill Armand when she
captures him in her Titan form and helps
train Aaron who reminds her of the most
important person in her life her father
Amy graduates fourth in the training
Corps but this is likely because she
slacked off so much while the others did
not many have said that Annie is one of
the strongest and most formidable Titan
shifters and there's evidence to support
that theory I mean Aaron Levi and Mikasa
not to mention everyone else failed to
capture her in the Titan forest which is
insane
I mean she single-handedly took out
Levi's squad in
diction Zeke the beast Titan does not
believe that amy has been captured when
he hears it from rider and death told
because he knows how strong and skilled
she is and the official guidebook it
points out that the reason Aaron's
attack Titan beat her in the final
battle is because she keeps trying to
flee while Aaron keeps going on the
offensive she does not seem to be trying
to defeat Aaron she seems to be trying
to climb the walls and escape it seems
like she's trying to return to her
father but Myka so shows up and cuts her
fingers off causing her to fall back
down
thinking still of her father and he
begins to cry before a seemingly
impenetrable crystal forms around her
four years later annie is still being
held underground in a giant crystal but
we know that sooner or later she will
get out and hopefully it's sooner
because she's been missing for like two
arcs now and that's a long time for the
sixth most popular characters to spend
chained up on the ground so now that we
talked about Annie let's look at the
female Titan and its unique abilities
Annie can use her unique fighting style
while in Titan form this style is
focused on minimizing the advantages of
larger stronger opponents through kicks
throws and holds out of the Titans we've
seen she has the best hand-to-hand
combat skills she also has insane
stamina after running alongside the
horses for an extended period of time
and fighting several difficult opponents
in the Titan forest she is still able to
use her vertical maneuvering gear a
human form to kill skilled soldiers then
she immediately transforms into the
female Titan for the second time and
escapes successfully her ability to
crystallize is also important she can
harden parts of her skin like her fists
or the nape of her neck
thus she can use this ability to
strengthen her attack and defense she
also uses this hardening ability to
scale walls disability isn't unique to
the female Titan as we know that Z the
beast Titan can also do it and Aaron
learns to do it later in his Titan form
as well it seems like Galliard can also
harden his skin not to mention the
hardening abilities of the armored Titan
so it is not a unique ability among the
Titans but what has not been seen in
other Titan shifters is Annie's ability
to create a crystal
cocoon around her human body that cannot
be broken by any known technology the
female Titan like the founding Titan can
control other Titans but the extent of
that control is unknown it seems that
she led the horde of titans that
eventually interrupted the survey cores
horse formation she was also able to
command the surrounding Titans to devour
her Titan body in the Titan forest while
she escaped in her human form right now
we can be assured that at the very least
and he can attract Titans
to her Titan form along with all Titans
and he can regenerate quickly however
she is the only one that has
demonstrated the ability to focus her
regeneration abilities on a specific
part of her body in order to massively
decrease regeneration time this is seen
when she catches the special operation
squad off-guard by using the ability to
regenerate one eye extremely quickly
many people have asked what happens if a
male Titan eats someone with a female
Titan power that's a good question and
the answer is we don't really know it's
never happened yet in the manga it might
be specific to women and males might not
be able to use it perhaps the power
would simply pass to a random LDN girl
if the possessor is eaten by a male
Titan but on the other hand a man might
be able to inherit it although I feel
like it might be too comical if it
actually happened case in point
imagine gene with boobs the fact is that
some female shifters like Amir and Peake
have Titan forms that look masculine so
it's possible in theory for a man's
Titan form to look feminine
who knows knowing at a contain anything
is possible but let me know what you
think so there you have it guys Amy and
the female Titan explained what do you
think about Annie do you think that
she's going to get out of her giant
crystal soon is it possible that she
switches sides because she always seemed
to be the most compassionate and least
committed male and warrior her last name
LED heart is derived from the Spanish
word Leon and the Dutch word heart these
words combine literally translate to
Lionheart which is usually what you call
a brave person or great hero similar to
Braveheart so will she also fight for
the freedom of her people or will she be
too worried for her father's safety to
act against marlane let me know what you
guys say
in the comment section below no matter
what decision she makes I can definitely
see her playing an important role in the
remainder of the story like always
thanks so much for watching guys I never
dreamed that a community would grow so
fast and I'm psyched to see what the
future holds if you liked this video
make sure to smash that like button and
if you haven't be sure to subscribe for
more attack on Titan videos until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you